you write quote I wonder if
self-improving AGI might end up
saturating physical environments with
intelligence
to such a degree that isolation of
individual mental States becomes almost
impossible
and the representations of all complex
self-organizing agents merge
permanently with each other
so that's a really interesting idea this
biological Network
life Network gets so dense
they might as well be seen as one
that's an interesting uh what do you
think that looks like what do you think
that saturation looks like what does it
feel like I think it's a possibility
it's just a vague possibility and I I
like to explain but um what this
looks like I think that the end game of
AGI is substrate agnostic that means
that uh AGI ultimately if it is being
built is going to be smart enough to
understand how AGI works this means it's
not going to be better than people at
egi research and can take over in
building the Next Generation but it
fully understands how it works and how
it's being implemented and also of
course understands how computation Works
in nature how to build new feedback
loops that you can turn into your own
circuits and this means that the AGI is
likely to virtualize itself into any
environment that can compute so it's not
breaking free from the Silicon substrate
and is going to move into the ecosystems
into our bodies our brains and is going
to merge with all the agency that it
finds there yeah so it's conceivable
that you end up with a completely
integrated information processing across
all Computing systems including
biological computation on Earth you that
we end up triggering some new step and
evolution where basically some Gaia is
being built over the entirety of All
Digital and biological computation
and if this happens then basically uh
everywhere around us you will have
agents that are connected and that are
representing and building models of the
world and their representations will
physically interact they will vibe with
each other and if you find yourself into
an environment an environment that is
saturated with modeling compute where
basically you uh almost every grain of
sand could be part of computation that
is at some point being started by the AI
um you could find yourself in a
situation where you cannot escape this
shared representation anymore and where
you indeed notice that everything in the
world has one shared resonant model of
everything that's happening on the
planet and you notice which part you are
in this thing and you become part of a
very larger almost holographic mind in
which all the parts are observing each
other and formal coherent role so you
lose the ability to notice to notice
yourself as a distinct entity now I
think that when you are conscious in
your own mind you notice yourself as a
distinct entity you notice yourself as a
self-reflexive Observer and I suspect
that we become conscious at the
beginning of our mental development not
at some very high level Consciousness
seems to be part of a training mechanism
that biological nervous systems have to
discover to become trainable because you
cannot take a nervous system like ours
and do stochastic related to sensors
back propagation over 100 layers and
this would not be stable on biological
neurons and so instead we start with
some colonizing principle in which a
part of the mental representations
form a notion of being a self-reflexive
absorber that is imposing coherence on
its environment and the spreads until
the boundary of your mind and if that
boundary is no longer clear-cut because
AI is jumping across substrates and it
would be interesting to see what the
global mind would look like that is
basically producing a globally coherent
language of thought and is representing
everything from all the possible Vantage
points
that's an interesting world the
intuition that this thing go out of is a
particular mental state and it's a state
that you find sometimes in literature
for instance Neil Gaiman describes it in
the ocean at the end of the lane and
it's this idea that or this experience
that there is this date in which you
feel that you know everything that can
be known and that in your normal human
mind you've only forgotten you've
forgotten that you are the entire
universe and some people describe this
after they've taken extremely large
amount of mushrooms or had a big
spiritual experience uh as a hippie in
their 20s and they notice basically that
they are in everything and their their
body is only one part of the universe
and nothing ends at their body and uh
actually everything is observing and
they are part of this big Observer and
the big Observer is focused on as one
local point in their body and their
personality and so on but we can
basically have this Oceanic state in
which we Have No Boundaries and our one
with everything and a lot of meditators
call this the non-dual state because you
no longer have the separation between
surf and world and as I said you can
explain the state relatively simply
without uh pan psychism or anything else
but just by breaking down the
constructed boundary between self and
world and our own mind but if you
combine this with the notion that the
systems are physically interacting to
the point where their representations
are merging and interacting with each
other you would literally Implement
something like this right it would still
be a representational state but you
would not be one with physics itself it
would still be coarse grained would
still be much slower than physics itself
but but it would be a representation in
which you become aware that you're part
of some kind of Global Information
processing system like thought and the
global mind and a conscious thought that
that coexisting with many other
self-reflexive thoughts
just I would love to observe that from a
video game design perspective how that
game looks
maybe you will after we build AGI and it
takes over
but would you be able to step away step
out at the whole thing just kind of
watch
you know the way we can now
sometimes when I'm on a crowded party or
something like this you step back and
you realize
all the different costumes all the
different interactions all the different
computation
that all the individual people are once
distinct from each other and at once all
the same but it's already what we do
right we can have thoughts that are
integrative and we have kind of thoughts
that are highly dissociated from
everything else and experiments
themselves as separate yeah but you want
to allow yourself to have those thoughts
sometimes you kind of resist it I think
that uh it's not normative I want it's
more descriptive I want to understand
the space of states that we can be in
and that people are reporting and uh
make sense of them it's not that I
believe that it's your job in life to
get to a particular kind of state and
then you get a high score
or maybe you do I I think you're really
against this high scoring thing I kind
of like yeah you're probably very
competitive and I'm not no not
competitive like role-playing games like
Skyrim it's not competitive there's a
there's a nice thing there's a nice
feeling where your experience points go
up you're not competing against anybody
but it's the world saying you're on the
right track here's a point that's the
game thing it's the game economy and I
found when I was playing games and was
getting addicted to these systems then I
would get into the game and hack it so I
get control over the scoring system and
would no longer be subject to it so
you're not no longer playing your trying
to hack it I don't want to be addicted
to anything I want to be in charge I
want to have agency over what I do add
addiction is the loss of control yes
addiction means that you're doing
something comparatively
and the opposite of free will is not
determinism it's compulsion
you don't want to lose yourself in in
the addiction to something nice
addiction to love to the
to the pleasant feelings we humans
experience no I find this uh gets old
right that's you I don't want to have
the best possible emotions I want to
have the most appropriate emotions I
don't want to have the best possible
experience I want to have an adequate
experience that is serving my goals the
stuff that I find meaningful in this
world